one of the two suspects in the
disappearance of a british journalist
hooded and masked police say he
confessed to killing dom phillips and
his guide bruno pereira and that he led
them to a site where human remains were
being dug up
from now on we move on to a new stage
the phase of identifying these human
remains which are being collected with
the greatest dignity
in order to preserve the chain of
custody and evidence which is very
important
the missing pair had been on a four-day
reporting trip in a remote part of the
amazon for a book mr phillips was
writing
they were last seen 11 days ago i think
the idea of the book was actually to
show the world what uh all sides
of the amazon conflict or the amazon uh
reality consisted on he wanted to give
this this human vision but unfortunately
that happened and this story is never
going to be told
two brothers anarildo and ozane de costa
who are local fishermen have been
arrested in what police say is a murder
investigation anarildo is the main
suspect in the case and police say he
told them he used a firearm to fatally
shoot his victims
his brother ozine denies any wrongdoing
and had previously claimed anarildo
confessed under torture
for days local indigenous people have
led the search at one point uncovering
items belonging to the pair
their friends and family had called on
authorities to do more to uncover what
happened
police are yet to confirm the identity
of the remains they found
and until then this community's wait for
answers continues sadia chowdhury sky
news